pack with me for a little parents
weekend getaway. we are only gone for
like 24 hours and I can way too much stuff
but so next time
he's super cute I think I love this time
and when you turn up so we are going for 24 hours
like I just said and I've no idea what we're doing
we're either going to have a 24 hour rot
and do nothing but relax and watch TV and read books
or like
a pool or check out the beach
downtown area who even knows
so we're packing a little bit of everything
packing my bathing suit cover up
just in case we go to the pool or hit the beach
one case the beach so that's probably not gonna happen
but just in case you never know
now for the outfit we need pair of pajamas
these might be the only thing I wear if we decide to bedrock all weekend
and I know my husband is from practice sweatshirt
that man lights our room at 65 degrees and does not care if I'm freezing
show me that and all different kinds of outfits
because you never know what you're gonna feel like
don't know what the weather is going to be like
there's apparently a Hurricane making its way towards the Gulf
so we could have really windy
rainy weather or maybe sunny
and how you do it so I got all the things just in case
I'd wear dresses if it's really hot in here
cause sometimes it's got a little bit of breeze
and I'm obsessed with this two piece set
it is so cute but
but it is open and these are all tasty bras
and when it is 100 degrees in here
those things slide off so pack it because I like it
might not get to wear that one
and a two piece car ride set
because girls gotta come to the car
but I can't lounge and drive at the same time I don't want
and there we go